Biden to forgive another $5 billion in
student debt for 74,000 borrowers just a
week after announcing separate plan are
you effective affected Yo Joe Biden is
pouring gasoline on this country and
lighting it on fire just GNA he's liter
he's just trying to purchase votes this
student loan stuff drives me nuts I
actually got my loans forgiven I it been
25 years and I hadn't missed a payment
which I think is why so they targeted me
first but no it's just just total
extraction of wealth I don't know where
that 5 billion is if they told Fanny May
or whoever these loan companies are
you're not getting your money back
that's a different story but if they're
printing 5 billion to hand it to these
private loan corporations and they're
just forcing you to pay back your loans
early with that's ridiculous because
it's costing us all money it's costing
us all um in in inflation it's it's
devaluing all of our currency by
printing money you know as we watch
Sports Illustrated crumble and Bud Light
may be on the verge of collapse Joe
Biden is just throwing money in the air
while screaming
yeea part of me thinks like we're going
to have to start rebuilding like we're
building the parallel economy we better
Crank That Thing Up Man CU we're going
to need institutions of our own to help
Sur to so that we
survive yeah and like for for someone
like Biden too it's like you make the
argument that this isn't sustainable you
can't keep doing this it's like why does
he care he's not going to be around and
you know to the point about like
purchasing votes like I mean didn't he
he already tried something like this
also and then it like got struck down or
whatever like these these people are
going to like turn on him too because
you know he's going to overpromise again
and you know I just don't think it's
going to work but even even like the
this plan right there if if it does like
it's it's not going to be sustainable
but he doesn't he doesn't really we had
uh you need people that are are willing
to say I don't want the free money
yeah that's just not going to happen
because the Titanic is hit the iceberg
and everybody's trying to steal as much
as they can before the ship sinks did
you hear the theory that the Titanic got
hit by a uboat got got sunk okay anyway
so uh I want to talk about that the the
the issue that we're dealing with is
that all of the people a large portion
of the people in this country are just
like let me extract from the system
whatever I can as it sinking and Joe
Biden is just making it rain and he's
like spend it while you can baby how do
we instantiate honor the in the species
to be like stop giving me this this
money I don't want it well I mean you
you can't do that to like kids that
already are like you know have already
got the debt you're you're not going to
get kids that have have signed on to
what they assumed was the you know the
deal if I go to school and I study and I
get a good you know get a good uh good
grades I'll get out and I'll get a good
job there will be a job for me that's
not the way that things are are panning
out um and and there's not a lot of
great answers for those kids um if they
spent a lot of money on a degree that
doesn't you know doesn't have a a job to
go with it or there's no you know no
market for that job they're kind of
effed we we had someone call into the
members only show and said that uh their
significant other was a trooper in Texas
and that they've begun discussing fears
of Civil War because the Biden
Administration may start arresting Texas
law
enforcement uh
I don't I don't I we have not confirmed
any of this and so Ju Just the general
idea is is difficult to bring up because
someone's saying it we reached out and
they're like no we don't want to talk
about this we're done and maybe it's
nothing maybe it's F fake news maybe
someone was lying to us to uh try and
sensationalize what's going on but it
the reason why it would make sense in
either direction is that Texas has begun
arresting illegal immigrants and we have
what is quite literally a fort SU
circumstance where the federal
government is saying this is our
jurisdiction and a state has deployed
armed soldiers to push them out and say
no it's not it's ours now for with Fort
Suter you have the Union forces at Fort
Suter and the South and the South
Carolina being like hey get out it's
ours now and then Union saying no now
you have federal law enforcement On the
Border saying the border is our
Authority and Texas National Guard
deployed armed soldiers to push them out
take control of the the area and begin
AR ing not illegal
immigrants sooner or later this reaches
ahead in some way either it's going to
be the federal government just gives up
and then other states recognize the
federal Authority is gone and eroded or
the federal government responds with
force or something like that happens I
bring it up in this context because I'm
like everything I see Joe Biden do and
the Democratic
establishment I I don't see any any
long-term planning I see them basically
just setting fire to the curtains before
they leave yeah I don't see the
long-term planning that's it does feel
like all like just kind of let's do
right now what's good for now no they're
like okay we're getting kicked out light
it up I knew a guy once who got evicted
from his apartment so he took Hershey's
syrup and he squirted it into the cracks
of every nook of the building yeah bad
guy and he was like that this will teach
him and I'm like I think you already
taught him by not paying rent but this
is the idea like the Democrats they're
getting evicted so they're like Set Fire
to the whole thing well I mean you know
the the fidi Trap stuff comes to mind
because the United States has a strong
economic power with a strong military
you know facing an up and cominging
China means you know conflict and the
idea that the United States needs to be
weaker um you know or a managed decline
that's not something that's that's so
farfetch or something that is hasn't
been discussed like Barack Obama
essentially said this you know said that
the United States was was going to
manage being not the only not the
superpower just be another country among
many and that takes a certain amount of
you know of management to get to the
point where the US economy is not the
dominant economy and also some level of
acqu Ence because like half the country
and I don't know the exact numbers is
like screw that no we're maintaining
hemon we are going to be America First
the greatest country on Earth try and
take it please because you're not going
to get it well I mean yeah there there
are people and the the thing is yes but
a big part of the problem is this hasn't
been proposed to the American people
there's no there was no like vote about
this or or you know or or you know any
kind of inquiry into hey America do you
want to start passing laws or signing on
to treaties that actually kind of weaken
the United States power you know over or
its own sovereignty
that you know um you know listening to
foreign powers like you knows and or or
whatever like do do we want the United
States to to sign on to those things and
and a lot of times the American people
don't pay attention and so because the
politicians that do sign on or that
actually are the ones that are like yes
we should plan this kind of stuff
because they that stuff happens quietly
your average person doesn't know so they
get reelected and and also like if they
had been like yo we're going to reduce
the American hegemonic power we want to
get rid of these American military bases
and we're going to co-parent the Earth
with the Chinese Communist party with
the Russians and with the corporations
I'd be open to that if you give me a
plan CU I don't like American Military
Police necessarily on its face it's
caused a lot of pain pain and suffering
probably unnecessarily but you better
give me a way that that's going to be
better than the LA the stability we've
had over the last 70 years they're
already making the play that I predicted
a couple weeks
ago Trump had received support from a
mere 56,000 caucus goers amounting to
some 7% of registered Republicans in the
state and just 3% of overall registered
voters in
Iowa they are already pushing the
narrative that Donald Trump is winning
in the absolute minority and they will
use that to justify barring him from
from power so my prediction was they're
going to remove him from the ball in a
bunch of States if they do Trump will
win the electoral college but the you
know if California removes Trump he
loses 10 million Republican votes he was
never going to win the electoral votes
in that state anyway but now he's going
to win the general election with 40
million to Biden 70 and they're going to
say this can't be all all the left is
going to say wow no one should be
president for on if with that little
votes this makes no sense that will be
their their in essence C's belly for why
they're okay with the use of force to
stop Trump from taking the presidency
even after he won the election they'll
say we're not the bad guys Trump didn't
actually win the system is broken he
only got you know
30% and they're going to he's not the
real president that's what they did in
Egypt they already want to abolish the
Electoral College so right exactly and
you're going to have Democrats coming
out and being like this country does not
want Donald Trump the majority of people
voted against him we should not allow
him to just use a technicality to take
power and turn this country into a
fascist dictatorship they are already
making the argument in Iowa 7% of the
voters voted for Trump and he won that
is not the will of the people they're
making an argument on quote unquote
democracy is that a real number I
thought that he he pulled what 70% of
the caucus itself but that was only 7%
record low voter turnout for the caucus
it was cold too that day was a bad vote
and Trump got uh yeah Trump trump got
around 7% of the registered Republicans
wow 7% and so but but this is how
elections happen what what's the
argument the Democrats the Republicans
who don't show up should have say no you
don't show up you didn't vote abstain
there you go your vote was abstain well
not showing up isn't a problem for
Democrats they mail you a ballot yeah I
mean and and honestly that isn't that is
worth mentioning if if you know people
are going to say things like oh well you
know showing up you know blah blah blah
BL blah it's like well you know maybe
they should show up if if their vote's
going to count right well Biden was
saying it meant nothing or whatever Iowa
means nothing but like he finished
fourth in Iowa in 2020 and then uh yeah
I know and then also like he got like
you know I think it was like 20 20,000
or something votes and it's you
know and he's the president so I don't
think there's going to be a super
Tuesday and this is this is rough for us
because we're we're trying to plan this
event we want to do a big like live show
in West Virginia but I'm just like man
we're going to spend all this money
setting up this live show and like
making tickets No One's Gonna Be left
yeah well yeah right no Nikki Haley and
Denis will drop out we thought we
thought Ron was going to drop out today
cuz he announced a press conference or
something so the Politico announced he
was having a press conference he never
showed up or he didn't show up for like
a half an hour I don't know what
happened did he ever show up I don't
know I didn't even see I verman Supreme
I tried looking for verman Supreme kept
popping up sent his Champion do Santa
sent his Champion instead well it was
funny because Laura lummer was like why
is this man who posed naked with Mickey
Mouse gloves appearing at a Ronda Santa
event and it's like it's a good question
but I don't blame Ron for Vermin Supreme
crashing the party yeah but either
either way if he was invited or not that
just like speaks to the state of his
campaign right now thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a member
over at timcast.net